welcome back to cbs this morning
recently created mass
vaccination sites like this one outside
of washington dc
to become bustling workhorses you could
say in the fight against the coronavirus
but for many people living in the rural
areas sites like these are impossible to
reach
our lead national correspondent david
bagno is here in studio
he's been looking into the challenges
david good morning it's so good to see
you but here's the question
many smaller hospitals say it just
hasn't been easy to get that vaccine
it hasn't good morning my friend good to
see you in person too let's start with
uh this
remember rural america wednesday we went
to columbus ohio where
the ohio state university medical center
appeared to be the first in the nation
to get the j j vaccine and actually put
it to use for them it's like an added
tool in the toolbox
along with pfizer and moderna then we
drove about four and a half hours south
into rural kentucky to see how j j is
helping
a 25 bed hospital
welcome to russell county kentucky
population
about 12 000. its largest town is
russell springs
that's about two hours south of
lexington and about two hours north of
nashville
the only hospital for miles is the
russell county hospital
we're not kidding when we say this is
rural america
paint the picture for us the uh
things you take for granted going to the
corner store or to a big box store
we're driving 30 40 50 miles meet
patrick branco
he is the hospital ceo he says prior to
this week the state of kentucky had only
sent his rural hospital
enough vaccines to vaccinate about 200
people
they stopped sending modern vaccine or
pfizer
out to the small rural communities
because they would rather get large
groups of people
my most vulnerable population in our
rural setting have a difficult time
getting access to the distribution sites
located in the urban
centers of the state
and that's why this was a big deal
yesterday he and his team received
200 vials of the johnson johnson vaccine
which can be stored in a regular
refrigerator when they called me up and
said you're going to get 200 doses on
wednesday
and two or three weeks you're going to
get on a regular cycle
of getting 200 doses every week that's
huge
i can start to address this entire
county well the work started right away
in fact the shipment arrived early and
at a rural hospital
everybody's got to pitch in
lab director lois moore took the lead
could you be here at 10 45 this morning
cassie hadley worked phones lining up
patients
miss alberta thomas was already on the
list and she was
out the door early this 90 year old
specifically wanted j j's vaccine
because she knew it would be one in
she's done
she hopped out of that car at the
hospital but she didn't want to go
inside though so she sat down in the
meditation garden
and they went to her hi there you're
gonna stick me i
am going to stick you all right there in
the kentucky sun
that is it it was done i hope it means
that i never
will have to have covet again oh i had
it
how bad was it the covet itself
wasn't that bad but the after effects oh
man
i have never known tiredness
or weakness i mean it was a case of
shall i sit here and starve or shall i
actually walk to the refrigerator
wow it was that bad that was that bad
hearing a 90 year old lady talk about
suffering with covet like that
is partly why the hospital ceo is so
thankful
to have j j here johnson johnson has
brought a product to our community
that's easier to administer easier to
store easier to get into the arms
and all three of those things for a
rural
really rural hospital like you means
what
it means we don't leave people behind
and that's my biggest concern
you can hear it in his voice we reached
out to the state health department for
comment in regards to kentucky halting
other vaccine shipments to the hospital
we didn't hear back
it's important to know kentucky is
sending about a hundred doses per week
to the russell county health department
so it's not just the hospital bearing
the burden
and miss alberta thomas she is 90 years
old
and she had 14 kids wow
wow she really painted quite a picture
david yeah yeah and she didn't want she
did not want to go in the hospital i
like how you said
she hopped out but she refused to go in
uh uh she said i'm not going in
she said i'll sit right here and you
come to me at 90 years old you can
dictate people like yes
you can order people around like that
and tell people to stick you
we all make it to 90. maybe we all do
that david begner going where the big
box stores are